on this very day I am trying the
greatest thing known to man
Heelys I had beauties for a lot of my
childhood and so this is gonna be like
throwback City for me co2 levels I'll
rock those all day but put me in
Keeley's might be a completely different
story I'm like so excited to do this
there's like a vein just like popping
and decide in my head that you can't see
right now these are pretty stylin these
are fat style clips any warning read
full warning on box and tag before
peeling off sticker never skate in or
near streets around traffic of stairs
skate that's the kind of [ __ ] that you
just tear right off as a kid you know
thank you I'm not the unseat they didn't
put it on this shoot so this year you
can just go to town and do whatever you
want
[Music]
that was the new bike I'm not doing this
right at all do you think you're about
to come up and roll into somebody and
you're just like
[Music]
if I walk I'm like my heel to window I
will fall so I thought going on heels to
be easy but I quickly realized that it
was gonna be a little harder than I
thought
I see five year-olds doing that like
champs all the time are you making fun
of me Kate when I first put them on it
took a minute to like get back into the
groove but it didn't take long so I'm
gonna make my second attempt of trying
to go down my huge hill behind me look
at those cars barreling down we're just
a bumpy it's hard better get to the
smooth Park but then when I got out on
the street I am was kind of a freak
because I'm here's this 23 year old
woman it's gliding through Los Angeles
like I'm a child okay so I'm starting to
think that these Healy's aren't as much
for me as they are for other people half
the time people are just looking around
at me like who is this woman child that
is skating in the middle of the street
I like oversteps and my like back foot
decides not to come with me and I ended
up in this split and I'm like don't know
how I got here
but I definitely blame Healy's for this
yeah I tried to do the spinning trick
and it was pretty tough the first couple
times but then once I like got the hang
of it and tried it on smoother surfaces
I was able to do fairly fun of the
Healy's was really just seeing strangers
reactions are you amazed by my like
magic
I was mostly effaced by the way you
appeared in this room and then just slid
into it my like perfect time to wear
heels was in my youth and I passed that
time now I'm just old that I can't do
anything outside of actual heels we
should do more stuff that's just for the
[ __ ] of it it doesn't have to be a
workout it doesn't have to be productive
for your work life you should just do
stuff because it's enjoyable and Healy's
are a great way to do that I think now
younger me is happy and now that I
finally use healings I can roll on with
my life some small child could use these
he leaves more than I could so probably
give them away to any up-and-coming
offers small children that want to try
helium